Three of three today is another Bernie question.
The question is, Hey David, how should Bernie
be handling protesters who interrupt his speeches?
So we actually had a voicemail last week from
a, a an angry Trumpist who said, Bernie is
weak.
Bernie is beta because protesters get up on
the stage and they take over the microphone
and Bernie just stands there.
Now there's a practical question and then
there's an ideological question.
The practical question is that it's lose lose
for Bernie because if Bernie is speaking and
protesters come on stage and commandeer the
microphone, if Bernie allows them to speak,
Oh wow.
Bernie is so weak and beta that he can't even
control his own stage.
If protesters come up and Bernie physically
blocks them from getting the microphone or
snatches the microphone away, particularly
if it is, you know, the topless female pro
protestors that have recently shown up at
Bernie's, uh, events, then, Oh my goodness,
Bernie is a misogynistic.
He's physically taking the microphone back
from these protesters and [inaudible].
So either way he is going to be criticized
by somebody.
Now the reality is go and look at Bernie's
background, right?
Bernie's background in the 60s sort of hippie
activist movement.
It's all about interrupting speeches, which
is a nonviolent form of activism.
So I would not be surprised if when Bernie
has this happened to him, he sees it nostalgically
in some sense.
And it's a throwback to when he was involved
in protest movements in the sixties and seventies
that did exactly this type of stuff.
Now I also want to point out, and this will
get us to the, to what is coming when it comes
to Bernie's a security situation, there is
a big difference between someone wanting to
speak and be heard versus someone looking
to harm Bernie Sanders or harm another candidate.
And if Bernie Sanders is the nominee, there
is going to be no shortage of people who want
to harm Bernie Sanders.
The antisemitism will explode and it's going
to be a mess.
So the real answer is if you want to prevent
this stuff from happening in the first place
and never even end up in the position of having
to stand aside while people commandeer the
mic or having to snatch the microphone back
from someone, the answer is you put in place
more security and this is ultimately going
to resolve itself because the major candidates
are going to get secret service protection
very, very soon.
Whoever is the nominee will of course get
secret service protection.
I have a friend of mine who works for a federal
agency who actually is going to be pulled
away to do additional secret service stuff
during the campaign and it's starting pretty
soon.
Under no circumstances would the secret service
let anyone interrupt or get close to Bernie
on stage.
We saw a couple of incidents back when it
was candidate Trump.
Remember in late 2015 or I guess it was more
more 2016 yeah, 2016 not 2015 where people
started to make an attempt to get on the stage
or whatever.
Trump has immediately pulled away the people
that are immediately tackled.
So the ability for anyone to grab the mic
at a Bernie rally is very soon going to completely,
uh, evaporate because of the secret service
protection that will soon be put in place.
Let me know what you think.
How should Bernie handle it?
Should he just prevent it altogether with
a stronger security presence?
Let me know.
I don't think this is the most important thing.
I do not evaluate candidates on the, of how
they react to people jumping onto the stage
trying to speak.
That's just not how I pick who I'm going to
vote for.
But maybe you're in a different camp.
Make sure that you check out today's bonus
show producer Pat common D. speaking of commandeering
producer Pat has commandeered the Friday bonus
show.
Check it out by becoming a member or a patron
membership.
Join pacman.com Patrion patrion.com/david
Pakman show.
We then have the South Carolina primary over
the weekend.
We then have super Tuesday next Tuesday, which
we will be covering live.
So a big upcoming 10 days
for the David Pakman show for progressive
media and for the continuing process of selecting
a democratic nominees for 2020 we'll see you
there.
The David Pakman show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].